this is a production of Cornell
University
and thank you very much
for having us here I want to touch bases
just on a construction standpoint what
the
the owners can expect to happen on site
what needs to be in place before we
arrive uh Jessica and Dale both did a
great job of explaining a lot of the
products of the cover installation uh
most if not all of the photos that were
shared today good and bad are from
environmental fabric installations we
have been doing this for quite some time
since the mid 90s all over the country
and abroad as well we've worked outside
of the country
various different operations aside from
agriculture but with our Focus here
today uh and the typical cover installed
in the uh Upstate New York basically
um is a 60 mil hdp material
it's high density polyethylene it's an
industry standard for this application
and some of the industrial applications
we do use a thicker material an 80 ml
even 100 Mil thickness of the same
material
um what we need to happen on site if it
is going to be a non-line system we
would like to see all of the mowing
around the Lagoon taken down
anything hard stem that may be growing
inside the slope of the Lagoon would
need to be removed and we can apply as
Jessica showed a
geotextile fabric to help as a a cushion
layer and to protect any uh abrasion
from happening to the bottom side of the
cover
um when the guys come on site typically
it'll be a a group of seven to ten guys
um a couple of pickup trucks an enclosed
trailer minimal equipment is needed
typically in a telehandler or lull type
forklift as well as a mini excavator for
any Excavating that we may need to do
uh of when we first come on site we like
to make a good introduction with the
owner find out exactly how he would like
us to enter and exit his property so
that we do not
uh get in any way shape or form the
daily operation of the the farm itself
um once that is in place we typically do
not need a lot of help from the farmer
we certainly welcome all the time they
have to come visit with us but we are
there to do our job and we do not want
to impede what they have going on on the
farm
so once the the
can anybody else hear Jason
I'm not hearing anything
Jason
hello Jason
can you uh right now we can hear you
okay it's been unmuted I'm not sure
what's happening there
okay do you want me to continue I'm not
sure where you may have heard or where
it may have left off
um I heard you uh talking about uh your
relationship with the farmer when you
arrive
okay so like I said we like to make sure
we we get his expectations for our the
way he wants us to come on to his
property sometimes there's a back gate
sometimes there's different interests
they would prefer to you so we don't get
in in the way of of the the process of
the farm
um typically after that we do not need a
lot of input from from the owner we do
not want to get in his way or slow him
down we we welcome him to come visit us
and ask any and all questions but on a
day-to-day during construction we are a
self-contained unit and we will stay
right around the perimeter of the
storage Lagoon itself
we uh once we have all the Landscaping
done and the mowing has taken place and
any vegetation has been removed we need
to establish that low water level
uh the stock pump if you will so that
the level never is pulled down below the
opening of the pipe so we do not have
gas backing up into manure collection
areas
or other areas that could cause harm to
animals as well
uh some piping influent and effluent
that may be existing and entering the
Lagoon at a higher elevation simply just
needs to be turned down to where it can
follow the slope down to the low water
level and once it's below the liquid
then we have that seal and we don't have
to worry from there it is important that
at the time of the cover installation
the liquid is at the low level stock
pump that way enough material is
introduced into Lagoon
to allow proper fluctuation throughout
the year as the Lagoon fills and is
emptied you don't want to put stress
around the perimeter trench so it is
important to install it at low water
level so during coordination it that
would be the time for the cover to come
out
um the typical size job in New York that
we have seen throughout the years we are
looking at about a three to six week
on-site window
again it's a small small crew the cover
uh is fabricated as she said in in a in
a manner that it's accordion folded and
then we launch it across and pull it
across so the cover can be built in a
few days and then it has launched across
in one day and secured either into the
anchor Trench or welded to the existing
liner
again I'm as I mentioned earlier it's
the the material thickness
um through the years we have seen uh
different
Technologies technological changes with
our material and our equipment as well
um the material they're making these
days are all a standard as material
there's really only two manufacturers
left in the U.S
and they make the material to the same
standard that material for a small
additional charge can carry up to a
20-year warranty
and Europe the same material made in the
same specifications
can can hold a 50-year warranty
um here in the U.S 20 years the Max and
that is a prorated warranty that is
given by the manufacturer us as the
installer will help with any uh warranty
claims we will be the liaison between
the owner and the material manufacturer
to help decide who is responsible for
what uh typically as an installer we
would provide a one or a two-year
installation warranty
um if properly maintained there's not a
lot of cover maintenance that needs to
be done from the outside where you hire
um Personnel we we ask that you visually
inspect the cover look for any debris
that may have been blown out onto the
cover we want to keep the rain water
pump down we don't want it to overflood
the cover but we do want to keep some
water in the troughs for for purposes of
cutting down the friction of the weight
pipe on the cover itself
um at any time during the life of the
cover that there is a damage whether
it's natural or or someone made a
mistake or something an animal got out
on the cover and damaged it we also and
and all cover installer should offer a a
repair service where even if the hole is
out in the lagoon the crew is trained to
come out and safely make that repair
um obviously if any manure is introduced
on top of the cover there are Services
there to clean that and remove it as
best we can pump what's contaminated
back into the cover to get you back to
where you are dealing with clean water
on top so it could be either pumped off
of the tile or collected for irrigation
um our our service we're here on the
East Coast but we work all over the
country I have many crews in California
where our predominantly all of our work
right now is in California we work year
round because of the weather and the the
the the vast amount of dairies that are
there
um there are a tremendous amount of
programs through the state of California
but developers and the potential for the
use of the gas there
um have has projects moving forward at a
rapid Pace even without state and
government funding
um as far as environmental Fabrics in
the state of New York we have
participated in many of these programs
and we understand that
um the way the programs work we we are
able to come in and install the cover
and understanding we need final approval
before we would get paid we're on a
typical job we may do progress billing
on some of these because they happen so
quickly we're able to come in fully
install the job and then once it's
approved through the program through the
grant funding then we're we're fine
we're getting paid at that point
[Music]
um
there is a few other pictures if you
want to go through some of these slides
and we can just talk about some of the
the prep there
so that's a liner going in yep that's
that's a liner going in as you can see
it's just basic dirt work we need it we
need the liner smoothed out I know a lot
of the new stores going in a lot of
states are requiring a liner
um
we it's it's it's we don't need it
smooth as glass we we need it to be free
of any big ruts or anything that could
damage the liner but our crews come in
the rolls are 22 foot wide and they are
placed in position piece by piece and
then welded together we've seen some
examples and we have a few pictures of
some welding going on here
um each seam where this material you can
see this the seams are very defined
there that each seam is tested
independently with air pressure to
assure that there's no leaks
um if you go ahead and go there's
there's a couple you can go back forward
there's another picture of of the
testing process along with some of the
pictures of the welders up close
but this material is thermally bonded so
it's it's it's heated and used pressure
to bond it together
um in the fusion process similar to how
polyethylene pipe is fused there you go
that that's a picture of what the
industry calls a wedge welder this is
what a predominantly does all of your
large seams and all of your production
work is done
underneath of that flap and the overlap
there is a heated wedge and it's heated
on both sides and the Machine actually
clamps down using pressure to create the
seam and it actually is self-propelled
so there's Wheels behind it that pull it
through the seam so our technicians are
there to clean the seam and to keep it
on track
the other type of welding is Extrusion
Welding which you see here which is not
unlike a a large scale
Jason I think we lost you again
can you hear us
comes out
this is done on any areas of that need
repairs this is done in any areas where
we have cross seams like you see in this
photo
go ahead and go one more please
Jen are you with me
there you go okay so this shows the
testing procedure that that the vice
grip is basically sealing off the end
and there's a gauge there hooked to the
needle that needle is put into the seam
between the two wheels that actually
provide the movement of the wedge welder
itself this is pumped up to 30 PSI and
can run the entire length of the seam as
long as there's no cross seams or any uh
damage in between that's left in place
for five minutes and you typically will
see Zero uh pressure down from that and
you know the seam uh is is going to hold
fine so here's another picture you can
see the track that it leaves behind it
the two outside are the wheel marks and
the the center of that is the actual air
chamber that's penetrated with that
needle intestine
this is a basic Flair controller this
flare itself is unlike what Dale showed
us Dale showed us an enclosed flare
which different programs throughout time
have had different requirements for
methane destruction
this open type flare with a shroud and
an igniter
um typically was not uh approved for
complete Destruction for accumulation of
credits or any any other type of process
but since then time have changed where
you get very minimal reduction because
of this because there is still total
Destruction what Dale showed us is an
enclosed flare which keeps the the flame
inside of it entirely this is a basic uh
torch like you've seen on many landfills
the the Shroud around it is just for
wind break purposes this one particular
in this picture is powered by the
landline power as Jessica mentioned
you're gonna need power to the Lagoon
for your rain water pumps so this is a
simple 110 connect connection is not uh
require any special uh electrical source
or power provided there we also do offer
those who would prefer to have a solar
system and if it's powered by solar the
technology has gotten much better
Through The Years where those are much
more reliable systems these systems have
a thermocouple that measures temperature
to tell the igniter to cut on and off
and also has a power source to get that
uh igniter sparking to to light the gas
off
all right Jess what else you got on here
okay this is very important and Jessica
mentioned this Jessica's Skinner
mentioned this this is something that
we're seeing now that 10 years ago we
weren't doing but this is an emergency
event it's very very basic and very easy
and
that valve that you see is typically
left closed and if there is an issue
with evacuating gas whether it's to the
flare or to a generator or whatever
purpose you have with the the gas you're
you're accumulating this can be opened
up the stack is high enough that it
allows the the excess gas to vent to
atmosphere and this would prevent you
from damaging the cover or or
potentially uh having it rupture or
damage the liner from from expansion
so these are something that we like to
see there's a there's another picture
this is your flow meter this is what's
typically used in both systems and and
our flare system that we provide
it has
uh this flow meter which has a
accumulator on it the totalizer you can
also hook this in where remote
monitoring is possible through cell
service and Data Logger as possible
where you can not only uh accumulate the
total flow but you can have temperature
for total Destruction
um through the information from the
thermocouple
Jason do you want me to go back to any
of the previous slides that we might
have gone through fast or shall we start
with questions
well we can start with questions like I
said I think the general that Jessica
did a great job of explaining the the
installation process and certainly my
information will be attached um any
anyone from from from from any aspect
because I welcome you to give me a call
we can talk about what we've been doing
this system is something that is one of
our uh more basic type systems and it's
more user friendly for the smaller scale
uh Farms so we we can we we offer this
all the way up to 30 000 head Mega
dairies out west so we we've got a
system in place to
we started out as a Liner Company we
we've done a lot of of cover work since
the mid 90s and this is what we focus on
so any anyone I can help anyone I could
point in the right direction or
providing information for them happy to
do it
um some questions uh is there a best
season to install a cover
well certainly in your area it is
um we we need drier temperatures we when
we start getting late in the year and
we've been in Upstate New York to
Halloween and and going into November
before we've had heavy snow but it's not
just the the the wet the condensation
that accumulates if you uh could imagine
it's plastic welding so any moisture
that gets in between there can cause an
issue for Quality so we need drier uh
seasons for sure we typically work North
during the Spring and Summer and work
South as much as we can and again in
California it's it's year round the rain
Seasons hit or miss
and I have a particular question uh we
were told that this gas is wet do you
have any problems with anything breaking
in the winter because of the wet gas
oline the condensation in in one thing
with these systems is the gas production
crawls during the winter because these
are ambient temperature digesters we're
not seeing huge production during the
winter
um but the condensate trap do needs to
be drained
um periodically again like Dale said he
vents it off when it's at low production
some folks close the valve and store it
under the cover but we we tried to
uh install below the frost line
um and and we we have not had any issues
with uh freeze-ups during the winter
do you have any supply chain issues
availability cost materials
uh well yes uh absolutely like everyone
else and just about every walk alive
we're we have seen the material pricing
level out uh we have actually went a
couple of months without the dreaded
increase as we've seen throughout the
entirety of 2021
um the the the the products that we use
are typically available and we are able
to order them enough in advance and keep
some in stock uh we do try to utilize
local uh folks especially for the
concrete for any PVC and for any usables
that we are going to use on
we try to purchase those locally so uh
area to area it may be a little bit
harder for certain things but right now
we're seeing PVC as a problem of course
the pricing for everything is is up
um but I I I hope that that's going to
continue to to stay where it's at and
then we'll see and start backing off it
was tremendously low for a long time so
some of it may not just be supply chain
are you aware of programs through which
farmers can sell carbon credits based on
the volume of methane that is flared
we do have some relationships with some
folks and there that has actually became
more and more of a reality
um through the years it's been more of a
mythical kind of a thing you it sounds
good and we've we've had clients talk
about it but the the the value of it
really wasn't there but we're starting
to see uh not only credits but we're
also starting to see ways to utilize the
gas that are are obviously going to be
uh returned in in cash
so uh certainly
there's uh the the as as we move forward
the technology is definitely moving in
the right way
do you have experience advice about
covering concrete circular or
rectangular takes
we have uh we have covered all types um
the the biggest thing is going to be how
you attach the cover and how you access
the the manure itself or the liquid
itself
um if if there are ways in place to to
do your mixing and to do loading and
unloading we can certainly attach a
polyethylene cover to
a concrete structure we have them both
uh supported and floating
um again as you start getting into more
and more of the the the supported intent
type and inflatable type covers the
costs are going to go up you're in
ground digesters are certainly more uh
economical
so uh a question about uh the cost
related to if you put in a cover at the
time that you put in the storage versus
putting in the storage and then coming
back sometime later to put in the cover
can you can you give us a sense on on if
it's more cost effective to do it all at
once or
marginal well depending on the size
um you're going to have some shipping
savings if you are able if if your your
liner itself has a partial truck or not
a con an entire truckload so you'll have
some savings there
um but obviously the more material that
we purchase we typically get better
pricing
um so there could be some some small
savings there as well
um the the biggest thing uh is that when
we do the liner we have to come back
anyway because there's going to be some
time where they're filling the Lagoon so
while we're waiting to get to stop pump
blood water level we typically
demobilize to another project so it's
it's not uh anything that we can just
continue on as far as time saving
super helpful thank you so much Jason
this was fantastic truly appreciate it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu